hey what's up welcome back to my channel
in this video you're gonna learn all
about rent to rent how to get a landlord
to say yes how to systemize a rent to
rent business and ultimately how to make
eight to twelve thousand pounds clean
profit per month through running a
rent-to-rent business i'm going to be
interviewing two of my students who've
become extremely successful over the
last 18 months or so so if you enjoy my
youtube channel please do me a big favor
help the algorithms out by smashing the
like button also if you've got questions
or comments throughout this discussion
comment below and we'll do our best to
answer your comments and questions but
firstly congratulations guys thank you
samia
you guys are killing it thank you how
long have you been watching winners on a
wednesday i've been watching it for a
good but i would say 18 months or so
pretty much since you started yeah yeah
you'd be sat here
never never i didn't i didn't think this
is never enough
even on my agenda of actually being here
right now this point in life i never
thought i would see it happening well
done well the reason you guys are on the
show the reason i've asked you to come
down thanks for coming is because you've
obviously partnered together in business
um you've been working with me quite
closely over the last 18 months you've
built up a rent to rent portfolio you're
making 8 to 12 000 pounds a month in
fact did you say the last 12 months
you've turned over how much 350k
geez absolutely incredible so i want to
really in this interview pull out how
you've done that how you guys have
partnered up what your story is um what
an average day looks like for you and
really for anyone watching this that
wants to get started into property
even if they've not really got much
money to start buying houses how to go
about doing that so firstly merlin why
don't you kick off how did you get into
property where did this all begin from
uh well for me um my background actually
funnily enough
in my career was
property management block management
right and it wasn't a path that i chose
i fell into it because i was starting
temping as a secretary doing different
work in different companies and then i
landed a job and it happened to be a
block management company and then my
career developed along that that field
and at the beginning i quite enjoyed it
you know because i was sort of single at
home with parents so that was fine but
as
my circumstances changed you know um got
married and stuff like that i began to
realize that actually i was getting very
very very unhappy it's been stuck in the
nine to five yeah um and so therefore i
started looking at i did actually start
looking at other courses and doing like
property courses and trying to see there
was a way of you know
swapping you know the day job getting
out of the day job um and then actually
as time unfolded um
i did dabble a little bit i did that a
little bit bought some properties sold
but it i didn't apply i was just not
applying it very well right and so
as time went on i got sucked back in i
didn't do anything when just got sucked
right back into the 95 and
every
company that i started to work for it
was getting more and more demanding and
i was getting very unhappy but anyway um
fast forward
i was looking at videos and stuff and i
came across
some leads
and it was inspirational and what struck
in my mind was a financial freedom
challenge and i've said to myself i want
to do that but i felt stuck i felt stuck
um and then
the pandemic happened and then
the company that i was working for was
restructuring and then i got let go
and so i thought you know instead of
just going back and working for a nine
to five i just took the leap of faith
because all that time i was doing doing
the studies learning i thought i'm gonna
make a go of it start from scratch
take a leap of faith and just go for it
and start building a rental rent
portfolio my strategy actually was
to get a few deals first sell it
get some money and then build a
portfolio that was my strategy and then
i came across sammy and he said to me
well actually why don't you keep it keep
your first deal and just build on it and
i thought okay let's let's do this so
when did you when did you guys make so
as merlin was doing the training review
um she was test product and she had a
nod on gumtree for a property in wembley
and obviously we'll get the high we
actually met when i give up about myself
so i was just at a time in life
searching for what when i actually went
for a chief executive job because i've
always consulted i've always been really
very good at growing businesses and
making businesses turn around so i said
go for it so wrong and i got through to
merlin we started chatting on the phone
i said let's meet let's have a
discussion so we met we then started we
we done an agreement went into joint
partnership together we signed the
agreement the following morning was her
first viewing i went with her i looked
around the property and i said i knew
nothing about bricks water or anything i
said marlene let's keep it i'll work
with you to make it work
we then managed to negotiate 12 weeks
rent free of the landlord within two
weeks the property was repainted and
decorated and fully furnished merlin had
tenants sitting in it from week two and
the property was making a profit before
the rent-free period was even over wow
yeah because i just just said let's go
for it full-time yeah forget about the
job and at this point then so you just
gone full time in property yeah not by
choice you'd be made redundant yeah
you'd hooked up with sammy sammy kind of
had a bit of a business background
didn't know lots about property
obviously you would just join the
academy which was which was awesome so
that first went to him where was that
where was that deal in white city
okay cool so you still got it today yes
how much profits it make 2 900 a month
oh my goodness
that's like
that's like financial freedom on one
deal pretty much yeah
so so at this point then presumably you
thought right we've got a business model
here
that works
rent to rent a lot of people say rent to
rent is still blessing it's illegal it's
just like having another job it's not a
proper business
there's loads and loads of downsides
people make it sound too good to be true
it's risky there's a lot of people that
talk about rental rent haven't done it
and i'm not saying that it's all
positive and it comes with zero risk and
zero work of course not but
what has been your experience of rental
events as a business model oh i think
it's i think it's great i think for
anyone that wants to work for themselves
and have that freedom of actually being
able to choose what matters getting into
something like rent the rents it's about
setting it up having your direct debits
for your flow of your bills having a
continuous cash flow coming in and
managing the property every 12 weeks so
that one property after it's set up is
flowing for three years if you have good
tenants in there you've got continuous
case flow coming in what made you guys
decide to partner up and not just do the
business on
alongside each other well my reason for
austin murray to win the business was
because she comes from property
corporate background and has 30 years of
experience
she's a lot older than myself so i
thought it would be good collaboration
young she's very intelligent and she
actually knew what she was doing yeah so
i i made the approach to consult for her
where i sing we could work together and
make perfect so what she's not too
strong at i am strong at but the two of
us together are super glue and that
works perfectly my background is um like
corporate as i said block management so
i
i was i've been in a property game for a
long time but
um as i said it was a new
area in terms of rent to rent building a
portfolio because what appealed to me
was i could take control of a property
and generate cash flow so my background
because it's been in the corporate
background and sammy's compliments mine
because he's from a business point of
view business consultancy
i think that we complement each other
because what i don't have he has and why
he hasn't got i've got and you know what
teaming up and joint venturing yeah it's
so so powerful because there's a saying
that says if you want to go fast go
alone but if you want to go far
go together that's it you can't do it on
your own believe me it's a what you know
man is an island so it's good to team up
so what made you
enroll into the academy and what was the
process of how did that work um like i
said um what struck me was the financial
freedom challenge and that drew me and
so i i saw there was a crash course that
was um and at the time i think it was it
was during the lockdown so it was an
online one yeah so i i actually joined
up on the cad on the um crash course and
of course after the crash course i've
learned so much that was phenomenal
and then i signed up for the
courses alongs right in addition to that
and this was all online so you went
online yeah you're registering online
online but then what happened when you
when you when you enrolled onto the
advanced training online well what
happened was on the it was amazing right
because
you sent a message to say
i'm going to visit one of your homes but
i didn't i didn't pay no mind to it i
just thought
i want to get on your courses and i
bought the course and that was it i
didn't think anything of it and then
about
i would say about an hour hour and a
half later um the bell rang
and i was on the phone i think i think
you contacted me as a follow-up so
that's nice he contacted me to follow up
because you know i got the course
and then my son came in the room and
said actually
samuel lee is actually
outside your front door because
yeah right yeah right
yeah you get right because not honestly
he's actually standing outside your door
and i'm like really put the phone down
but i'm just speaking to him on the
phone
walked out there he was you you were
standing there
like what and then you handed me the
actual course material right yeah yeah
and i was so blown away and i thought
wow isn't that amazing that
you know you actually took the time to
come to my home handed me the course
material i said you know what this is
somebody that i would love to actually
continue working with at some point in
the future but also continue learning
from yeah amazing the thing is as well i
think that online has its place but i
don't think you can beat person to
person no eyeball to eyeball so when i
saw that you just enrolled onto the
academy and we were in lockdown and
stuff and i didn't break any rules
coming because i can't remember the
exact rules at the time but uh
technically i was a delivery man right
because i was delivering your materials
or at the door no different from a
postman coming um but but you know we
chatted and connected and you know
at that point you'd just be made
redundant right and you were kind of
like i need this to work okay so that
first property then that you guys teamed
up and got where did it go from there so
you got one property it's it's it you've
got a rent-free period 2 800 pounds a
month profit so we we then came away
from that on that day and driving back
and we said okay
let's go let's run it now let's do it so
and the yeses are coming through
i went home and marlene obviously
because i was in the ground before the
campaign blast and the phone rung within
48 hours after saying a nut deal we had
a landlord from slay offering us a five
bed so marlene can go into detail with
that property because that's another
story that's she took the leap into
supported accommodation route with that
property
so um we took that on we then berlin
obviously when she was going through the
training with herself she had touched
base with a guy had had a property in
cheshire so we went to crew and we took
on a five bed there for a low rental
like just in the peak time of the summer
for service accommodation so we done a
duel we had rent the rent so the rents
covered the the rent of the landlord and
the other three rooms would be serviced
accommodation and that would be the
profit the us
that worked so it's like a hybrid yeah
yeah yeah yeah how does that work
because um we always want people to be
careful of mixing tenants and guests um
unless the house is very kind of
separate but how you know what's it
worked well
for some reason i mean at the end of the
day it because the tenants the few
tenants that were in there um
because of the layout of the house it's
sort of compartmentalized right yeah
yeah okay and so basically the two rooms
that we had had the guests come through
and the other rooms the tenants were
there and we let them know what yeah
what was you know they were also like
that yeah
we're doing a hybrid so your talents
that you have there it's two ways you
can you can work at it so
you can give them an incentive to let
them know there's people obviously
serviced accommodation you can earn the
cleaning fee you can earn that so then
that gives your talent the incentive so
his rent then is going to become cheaper
right so and then also obviously
with a lot of clients in the pandemic
today's worker samuel is tomorrow's
universal credit claimant yeah so
and that to me is secure rental income
because it's it's secured from the
government a lot of landlords out there
don't look at people on universal
credits they don't want to work with
them or help them but it's actually a
gap for companies that's taking them
around the rent to secure your money
makes sense i mean i think we actually i
don't know if you were there in person
we did a service accommodation training
program recently and we said if you're
going to split and do a mix we said
there's three c's you need to do number
one is car park um compartmentalize the
house
number two is clarity be really clear
with the tenants up front so they know
what's happening and then number three
is cleaners make sure you've got the
right cleaners so that it's you know
it's sort of systemized so it sounds
like you've done that and knocked out
the park um how much money did you have
to put into this business to start with
i would i say i put in 12k 12k
yeah okay i put on zero
so so you what did you what how how do
you work out what you do is a question
when doing a joint venture agreement
it's really important that you're
bringing equal value equal risk equal
reward to the table you're putting 12
grand now look it's worked out right you
guys are making 350 000 pounds a year
turnover but
how did you come to the conclusions and
and talk to me about getting that
clarity on your joint venture so so the
first deal which was that that's the
joint venture i've initially started on
the first property so marlene put the
kaishak woody into that and i put the
sweat equity into that so what does that
mean sweat equity he did all that
renovations
that was my that was my way of getting
into the deal and then also consulting
formerly moving forward on other deals
so that's a really interesting point
because for someone watching this it's
thinking oh i don't have the 12 grand
well then you can do what sammy did
which would say look i ain't got the 12
grand or i don't want to put the 12
grand in but i'll put sweat equity you
put money in and i'll put time and
effort and energy in and that can be a
joint venture but let's face it 12 grand
it's not a huge amount of money to put
in considering that now
that was stretched over three properties
by the way just not just one property we
managed to cross train them
yeah
in total yeah so we managed to sort of
budget it down and make it worse these
fingers were good in the sweater yeah
yeah
right so okay so 12 000 pounds you
stretch that across training rent to
rents you then started making some money
you put it into more insurance and you
just recycled and recycled how many how
many properties do you have now under
control we have 11.
on 11 that we have food control on and
we have four that we have subcontracted
out to
other people that started the journey
but because they were new the landlords
obviously getting to know credibility
and stuff were happy for us to
subcontract it out so it's then merlinia
has given the other students support on
high to get onto the journey so again
it's like part again though man this is
blowing me away because some people say
i haven't got the money and i also
haven't got the credit i won't pass the
references it's like and that's why on
the academy people do business with each
other all the time because it's like
what what you might not have someone
else does have how can you work together
because at the beginning that was the
the barrier when i first started i had
nothing and of course landlords would
ask you what's your track record what's
your history so it's just breaking
through that barrier and once you get
the first one you can you kind of like
win them over you say you offer them a
guaranteed rent insurance and stuff like
that to get on and then you build a
portfolio and now you've got track
record and that's what a lot of people
i realize had difficulty in doing is
getting that step getting that track
record so then we can actually help them
yeah and that's what we did sub sub it
out and so they can build them that
makes sense and and i think as well when
you're starting out your first deal is
always your hardest but once you get the
set set up and the contracts and the
systems and the procedures on your first
deal it's then rolling out what you've
done so moving forward
where are you going now what's the
direction of your property business well
developments right so
obviously
through the year one and obviously
creating that revenue and also securing
the contracts for three to five years on
rent the rent agreements
we now know that we have a continuous
cash flow coming into the business so
now the next step because we have now
managed to build relationships with our
landlord clients who now want to develop
they've got the finances to develop and
we and i on that we've got the sites to
develop so it's again perfect
collaboration for jv
and we're actually
just through the rent the rents yeah we
secure two development deals which one
is undergoing i in wimbledon we have a
conversion from a shed to a one-bed
summer cabin wow
and we also now in maidenhead we have a
full renovation of a property and a
double rear extension and six months ago
i wouldn't be able to tell you but
scaffolding was told cement
that's incredible yeah so you have the
offshoots now
yeah developing so i'm really excited in
that direction to be honest and what
about your hotel oh yeah that's yes
that's that's in the pipeline as well
where one of the landlords has said look
i'm taking on a hotel in i think in
blackpool yeah so that's sort of right
in the pipeline once he gets that yeah
he wants to hand that over to us wow
so there's a lot of things
in two years man because that's about
how long you guys have been doing this
right no 10 months no less than that
less than that yeah we're in the whole
training and everything yes two years
but actually business business wise
kicked off list just a year incredible
and now doing development deals um
buying up stolen service accommodation
we're actually we've actually took a
rental rent on in northern ireland in
lauren and uh the landlord client is now
looking at a 56 bed on a 36 bed two
properties in northern ireland that he
wants to buy and then he wants us to
work on the sweat equity on getting it
set up construction is developing and
turning it into our hotels
and that's that's where i come in from
too because in belfast
photo the best city in the world to go
on view but in 10 15 years time the
value in that city is going to go up is
that where you're from are you from are
you from belfast yep amazing and what
about yourself where are you from from
well born and raised here but my family
is from the caribbean from grenada
america
yeah i've actually i've actually
actually got another site a project that
i'm working on in um commercial fishing
in the caribbean so and that's the boat
it's just about to be launched
incredible so that project yeah yeah but
you are looking yeah so i assessment
yeah angela investor yeah just just for
it to get
on the water because it's almost there
yeah so once that gets on the water it
will be actually but the thing is as
well the same way that you guys did the
joint ventures and stuff on the rent to
rents it's the same skills on the bigger
stuff because how you do anything it's
how you do everything
so it's the same and also the the stuff
that the lessons that you learn from
rent to rent you can apply to bigger
deals the actual um landlords are
developers and they're now passing you
deals so
do you think rent of rent is a good
starting point for people to want to get
into property yes yeah definitely if you
if you cannot get onto the property
ladder because that's the thing you've
got you know it's the deposit and the
mortgage
you can take make cash flow by take just
taking control over property and
generating a positive cash flow that's
it and then you can build that base
and on the journey you will develop
relationships with the landlords and a
lot of the landlords are portfolio
landlords anyway yes and once they they
get the confidence in you
then things open up and that's what's
happening what's in it for the landlord
why would the landlord receive a small
monthly rent from you for you then to
just make an absolute killing i think
it's because that they have it's a
relationship and i think because they
can see for example the in maidenhead
they can see
that you they're they're time poor right
so at the end of the day they actually
have their confidence is in in myself
right to help
them grow their portfolio or help them
in their projects
so that's what it is i think that's what
the landlord is and then also the
landlords are on every landlord on their
own journey so they're out doing bigger
projects so they're looking maybe at a
single let okay if i'm looking at
building at
16 bear two bed flats in bracknell why
am i gonna be so focused on a 1550
single that when i can give out their
management company on an agreement for
three years i'm getting guaranteed what
i want out of that property yeah i have
no headache they're going to take care
of the maintenance and repairs there's a
landlord insurance in it so it's a
win-win yeah for everyone
i think as well
it's about the landlord might not
necessarily have the time but they might
also have the knowledge of how to
systemize service accommodation well
that's perfect but sorry sorry to stop
there but perfect what you say because
this particular landlord that we're
talking about he has every day we speak
to him we're finding he's in another
property another property but he doesn't
know about service accommodation he
doesn't know about hmo he doesn't know
about rent to rent so
that they're now eating it
has went in and secured that one deal
she's four properties off the landlord
now yeah plus he's got another one plus
this double rear extension so that's
because it's a it's ultimately it's a
business and it's not like some people
think oh the landlord might just steal
the idea and do it himself but it's like
well no because if they don't understand
how to systemize it and how to actually
run it it's a business exactly
why don't everyone just do the hotel
business or why don't because they don't
know and understand that business and
then obviously it's the marketing like
avivo like the landlords are thinking
still back in the olden days where it's
tan and fine fees or there's that
they're sticking to the oldest agents
yeah proper or when they're meeting
night people it's serious giving them
the money i'm working
to me start the journey now yeah don't
do
i obviously i've been the reason why i
wasn't obviously in work and got onto
this i was actually uh going through
mental health um i was diagnosed with
adhd
uh just three months ago so in the whole
process of this i've actually been
getting assessed for for adhd so even
people with disabilities don't be scared
to stand up and take that chance because
you're gifted and you can go out there
and make did you do well in school no
terrible terrible interesting so
i've always been gifted like from 11
year old i've always buyed and sell
people in belfast used to call me offer
daily because i would have when i was 12
years old my i have seven brothers one
sister yeah my mom and dad would have
got us out they pulled all the wheelie
bins down and we charged two pounds we
washed the wheelie bins took them back
500 houses two pounder house that's a
thousand pound i was doing that from 12
year old to selling football t-shirts
after shave today i'm mentoring young
people today i'm going on to take on
hospitalities bars and restaurants it's
not making no money taking them looking
at the business hiding me change it
renting out the rooms i've took on uh
hotels in somerset so it's all been
business but my focus has been going in
six months seeing what i can do and then
moving on to help the next business and
i think it just shows to show the power
of you know sometimes people say i can't
do this because and everyone's got to
because it might be i didn't do good in
school i've got i've got adhd as well
right or it could be um i'm from the
wrong kind of background or i'm the
wrong
age or whatever but actually it's about
saying what have i got going for me yeah
and the things that i haven't i'll bring
someone in as a partner yep exactly
because i he's he's street smarts i
would say and i'm sort of book smart
yeah from the corporate sort of like you
know what's the
what what's the process of the academy
then so what's that what i know that was
like a year and a half ago now yeah well
you know i i i've got like i said i've
got it online and i literally i do the
courses you know obviously i've been
very busy so uh but i've did the
completed the lease option course i've
completed the deal deal
so literally it's been
phenomenal because it's like you're
coming to you you're actually a personal
tutor
click on the button and then we just i
just follow through what also you liked
about obviously the training with samuel
was the mentor and support that she
could always have someone at the other
end of the line phenomenal
i think that that's what helped me along
the way because the 365 they provide you
provide the mentorship every day every
day i can just book a call and say look
i'm a bit stuck on this can you help me
with this and that's
that was it that really really helped
because i think that's like i said i've
been on other property courses but this
was actually unique because you can
actually someone's at the end of the
phone at the whatever topic you want hmo
lease option or whatever it is you could
call them and then they give you the
advice and actually that was what got me
my first deal tipped it over to get my
first deal with regards to credibility
because it was like i haven't got track
record however they suggested the
landlord guaranteed rent insurance and
then they took it and that's how i got
my deal that's how i got it over the
line so you booked a mentor and call and
just said to us
hey i've got this deal but they're
asking me these questions
yeah that's awesome and that's i think
it shows the power of and i know you
later went on you've done some of the
training on the development side but it
just shows the power of you know all
i think
for me it's so important to not try and
reinvent the wheel but to find someone
that's because you can't know everything
about everything and you can't be ready
you don't know what you don't know yeah
yeah so um you know it's obviously been
amazing you were on the e academy yeah
you've done the development training
what was it like it was amazing like
that manual handbook like obviously has
just spoken about not having an
education going but i've always had like
the knowledge of what i want to learn
and think but that training manual and
the way you explain it and you're upbeat
and you're straight up front this is
what it is let it get and do it but the
main thing that stopped for me and that
whole thing was the form for warium when
the way you explained that and it is
that concept that will make you make you
successful
in a prayers offer and know what they
offer um ria's finance i manage the team
so that to me is was a real big benefit
for me going on that train because easy
to think that with property development
these deals you need to know everything
loads but you don't you just need people
around you that can you just need to
know basically what you're doing have a
business and this is like where i
believe in like taming and fiat and
everything happening and with the
development that's happening in
wimbledon like before that we wouldn't
have been that's the first major
development that we're actually project
managing and actually that it's worked
successfully and with 901 that we can
were to get the cheapest three quotes
and that full set up and do it within
the budget and work with the council so
to me
in the property journey if you want the
you you can have that name to fiverr but
stuck on that dead end job or it's
routine we're in a property journal
something different happens every day if
you laugh
or you cry but you will have software
make sure you have fun along the way
yeah
what does it feel like being full-time
property investors
amazing
phenomenal phenomenal yes i mean i feel
i've got out of jail you know obviously
there's nothing wrong with having a job
but because i've done that for so long
it's just a different feeling i feel
like i'm in a driving seat and it's
phenomenal absolutely phenomenal i've
always done business and hospitality and
this is the first way direction of an
end of property and the cash flow on the
money that can come through yeah and
this is just the start of what we can
actually achieve yeah
just even coming on today like the
consultancy and merlin has got
marines got a load of deals ready to go
for new people that want to start the
journey we have properties in essex we
have properties
maidenhead maidenhead how would you say
life um how's life changed as a result
of property well i was living in a
household
a four-bed house sure
with three three other guys within 12
weeks i moved into
one of our rental rents
so i'm living there now with my partner
and her two children on a three-bed
property
so from going from a house shower to
that um
everything in life like financially and
working with merlin and investment
is what we're planning in this year but
definitely i would never look back for
me for me it's actually
um time and work-life balance um as you
you might have been aware for the last i
think a few months ago oh no december
i suffered a bereavement and also i had
like illness at home my husband and so
therefore i was able to take the time
off
and look after him and you know sort of
like
and
if i was in a nine to five it would have
been difficult for me to sort of take
time off work so it's the flexibility
that that was that's the big big one for
me i was able to just take a step back
and actually
yeah
it it i was able to just do that yeah
that's awesome well you guys are amazing
and i'm so proud of what you've done and
what you've achieved and excited to what
you're going to achieve what will be for
people watching this final
i would say number one invest in
yourself
get educated and just take that action
and be consistent with the action and
have a goal and that's it keep going
amazing
well guys i hope you enjoyed the
interview if you want to connect with
merlin and sami i will leave their
details in the description below also if
you want to come down to the online or
in-person property investors crash
course i'm also going to leave a link in
the description for that and also every
single week for the last three years
i've been interviewing people that have
become financially free using strategies
like deal sourcing hmos rent to rent
every week so if you want to see more
stories like this you can check out my
entire playlist right here and choose
your favorite story also don't forget to
come on to the property investors crash
course subscribe to the channel and we
will see you next time
[Music]